[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le dressage a pour but de rendre à
cheval agréable et facile à monter
c'est à dire bien équilibré et qui
procure aux cavaliers et sensation de
sécurité réalisés avec tony del rosso ce
programme met en oeuvre les techniques
et des gestes les plus élémentaires que
tout cavalier doit exécuté à la
perfection afin de sentir et de
comprendre comment se déplacent le
cheval jusqu'à obtenir des mouvements
dans l'exécution se fait sans
contraction
[Musique]
on
au delà de toutes ces connaissances
acquises par le suivi des coûts le
cavalier désireux de dresser un cheval
va devoir se livrer à d'autres types de
réflexion afin de comprendre son
compagnon le pansage et la préparation
de l'animal sont une excellente occasion
d'établir des relations mutuelles d'un
très grand intérêt que le pansage ces
sites un massage mais on va plus loin du
sang des étirements qui vont dans le
sens de relaxer les muscles qui vont
fonctionner le pansage doit être
agréable au cheval il n'y a pas de
raison de le frotter dure jusqu'à ce que
soient désagréables pour lui au
contraire pour ça reste agréable
donc ça crée des liens bien sûr puisque
vous mis la pression tout pressage de
peut être obtenu qu'au moyen d'un
langage simple que lecavalier établira
avec son cheval
oh
soucieux du confort de celui ci le
cavalier met en place le harnachement
avec d'infinies précautions en soignant
tout particulièrement la mise en place
du mort ce dernier ne doit en aucun cas
pour ôter de blessures à la bouche du
cheval ce que le cavaly pour un soin de
vérifier avant tout séance de travail
l'offre de l'emploi d'un cap sont le
cavalier s'assure avec précision que
celui ci est parfaitement mise en place
sur le chanfrein et n'occasionne aucune
gêne douleur au cheval en effectuant en
douceur quelques fractions à rennes
vallier je te ra les bases du langage
l'astre
appel de langue à un chambrier haut
d'où à la louvière voilà
[Musique]
les flexions sont un des moyens les plus
puissants dont dispose le cavalier pour
obtenir de son cheval des sessions de la
nuque et de la mâchoire et de l'encolure
les flexions c'était comme si on était
sculpteur et qu'on mette le fal d'abord
à l'arrêt puis en mouvement dans une
certaine position et les flexions
permettent de mettre le cheval dans la
position qu'on veut celui que faire
quand on fait des demandes les plus
petites possibles est plus courte
possible que le cheval cède à cette
demande et qu'on est con cessent
immédiatement lorsqu'on a obtenu la
demande qu'on a demandé ce qui fait que
le cheval se met petit à petit dans une
position souhaitable elle qui va l'aider
à à pouvoir faire le mouvement les
flexions pied-à-terre doivent précéder
toute séance de travail la flexion
directe c'est-à-dire une flexion de la
nuque suivie d'une session de la
mâchoire conduite aura mené c'est à dire
que le chanfrein se trouve légèrement en
avant de la verticale
[Applaudissements]
les flexions latéral doivent être
effectués en tenant compte de la
morphologie du cheval pour ne pas
arriver à une encolure caoutchouc
les flexions latéral ans elles sont
demandées par une légère vibration sur
la reine qui aura pour effet de faire
céder le cheval dans la bouche
la flexion latéral doit après quelques
séances être exécutée facilement au pas
le cheval est entretenue dans le
mouvement par les jambes en place les
quatre membres se déplacent exactement
comme si le cheval était droit
[Musique]
au beaucoup
le travail à la longe trop souvent
utilisée comme moyen de détente rapide
est un véritable acte de dressage
aussi est il indispensable d'utiliser
deux longes afin de placer le cheval
dans une bonne attitude
les rênes sont montés sur le caleçon et
l'on peut s'aider d'une cordelette placé
à la façon d'une martingale fixe entre
la sangle et la muse rôle
conscient ce dispositif donne à la reine
intérieur en effet latéral permettant de
ployer l'encolure et à la reine
extérieur en effet d'appui sur l'arrière
main qui a pour résultat d'incurver
correctement le cheval voilà le longeur
ne restent pas statique mais se déplace
lui-même sur un cercle ou un carré dont
il arrondit les angles
le cheval a tiré par la mobilité de
l'homme reviendra peu à peu à calquer
ses déplacements sur ceux de son
professeur galle
c'est avec le travail à la longe que le
dresseur va perfectionner le langage des
aides est associé celui ci aux actions
de rennes à eau
voilà nous ou nous voilà au
aux longues rênes comme à la longe le
cheval a tendance à se coucher sur le
cercle dans le but de garantir le
mouvement en avant le dresseur se place
à hauteur des hanches pour garder le
cheval devant lui s'il est
convenablement travail et le cheval peut
rapidement effectuer des changements de
main les rênes étant toujours tendu afin
de limiter les conséquences d'éventuels
désordres
le dresseur associera à ce travail sur
le cercle des transitions d' allure en
allongeant sur le droit et en
raccourcissant sur le cercle
ce travail à base d'incubation répéter
régularisés par la reine extérieur fera
rapidement venir le cheval à l'extension
d'encolure avant même que le dresseur
net agit sur la bouche à eau aux as
tout l'art est de cheval avec les mains
puisqu'il sait pas s'arrêter avec les
jambes animaux siècle j'ai juste mais
rennes je ferme mes gens contactent jeu
mais les éperons contact si je vois le
bouge pas je lâche mes rennes je le
garde mes jambes au contact et je
dessers doucement fr et les gens il
vient d'accepter l'arrêt sur les très
bons contacts
s'il bouge pas je il a inspiré il a jeté
ses atouts semant les fermer les volets
bien là juste les rênes jeu refaire sans
nouvelle allure je vais faire mes jambes
fermées et rompt le cheval défilé calme
mais ça veut dire que tu en dis lâcher
les rênes et dessert les faire voilà je
peux le faire plusieurs fois de suite
j'ajuste une reine fermer ses pompes
fermées jambes je lâche délais je
dessers les faire et là je veux avoir la
rai si l'action il l'a compris je vais
avoir la neige à l'assiette et aux
jambes
l appui et je dessers doucement quand le
cheval cette amérique des preuves
avancées
des peluches mal avant tout va bien je
lâche mais là et je désire les faire
voilà donc comment cela juste mais
réelle je serre mais mon collège fermait
éponge monde son dos dès que là il va
lentement je lâche mes rêves et des
réalités
le secret c'est de desserrer les mains
des tentes des rennes avant de desserrer
les et problème
toujours pourquoi parce que ça arrondit
sur la plage de l'ice arrondi l'essence
ont entendu elle s'étire et là
maintenant il va comprendre l'arrêt sur
la sieste au pot ou
[Musique]
et le dessert je recommence je juge de m
à
ah voilà
[Musique]
lecavalier a très souvent l'occasion
d'utiliser l'action de jambes isoler la
jambe et dites isolées
lorsqu'elle agit en avant ou en arrière
de sa position habituelle la jambe isolé
agi par pression discontinue en
alternance avec la jambe d'impulsion et
perpendiculairement aux flancs du cheval
l'utilisation des mains et du poids du
corps peuvent différer d'un exercice à
l'autre là la jambe et au centre
première position de base ou le cheval
vacille incurvé dessus si on presse le
cheval si un choeur dessus la haie
l'éperon vient juste toucher la sas et
les jambes au centre jambes avancé pour
arrêter sur al ici un contact c'est
uniquement pour arrêter les deux en même
temps les deux jambes en même temps et
là ici ici pour déplacer les hanches
cheval qui a été placée en eux une jambe
au centre ça déplace toute la masse du
cheval là en même temps il n'y a pas
besoin de faire autre chose si je recule
la jambe ça déplace les hanches
voilà là ce sont les anges si j'avance
la jambe ça sort les épaules ça pousse
plus les épaules et ça pousse le cheval
dans les angles ça évite de faire cette
fameuse reine l'appui l'intérieur qui
est négative quand j'avance ma jambe je
pousse tout cheval vers l'extérieur j'ai
pas besoin d'eux
[Musique]
l'incubation du cheval n'est pas un
exercice aussi simple qu'il y paraît au
début du dressage de cavalli engage son
cheval sur le cercle à main gauche par
une légère rennes d'ouverture gauche
le poids du corps restant également
répartis sur la selle à ce moment la
jambe gauche puis l'ensemble du corps
par une pression perpendiculaire au
flanc pour éviter le dérapage des
hanches vers l'extérieur la jambe droite
recule il agit en jambes isoler la reine
intérieure indique le pli et la reine
extérieurs restent en contact sur
l'encolure sans venir en opposition avec
l'autre rennes
l'incubation est sans doute l'une des
notions les plus importantes dans le
dressage du cheval
il est possible de modifier la taille du
cercle plus le cercle sera grand -
l'incubation sera prononcé et
inversement plus le cercle sera petit
plus la curation sera prononcé
[Musique]
pour agrandir le cercle la jambe
intérieur agi avec plus de pression que
la jambe extérieure qui surveille les
hanches la main extérieure étant au
contact de l'encolure reçoit l'action de
la jambe intérieur et ne laisse pas
échapper les épaules cet exercice est la
jambe intérieure douce le chevalet les
descendants conduire le cavalier porte
ses épaules et son regard vers
l'extérieur de la courbe ce qui modifie
la répartition de son poids pour
rétrécir le cercle la reine extérieur
par l'intensité de son action incite
l'ensemble du corps du cheval à se
rapprocher du centre la jambe extérieure
doit surveiller la place des hanches
avec plus d'attention car un cercle
réduit augmente les chances de dérapage
la jambe intérieur permet l'incubation
en conservant son rôle de pivot
sans s'opposer aux déplacements
concentriques
les épaules et le poids du cavalier se
portent vers l'intérieur de la courbe
modifiant la répartition du temps la
main à l'intérieur conserve une action
discrète se limitant à indiquer le pli
s'ils sont mal exécuté ces exercices
peuvent provoquer au cheval des douleurs
le conduisant au refus le cavalier aura
soin d'obtenir un abaissement de
l'encolure seule position compatible
avec une incubation correcte du cheval
[Musique]
lorsque le cheval est habitué à cet
exercice
le cavalier ne le fais plus rentrer sur
le cercle par l'action de la reine
intérieure mais par son épaule extérieur
qui avant sera parallèlement à l'épaule
extérieur du cheval le contact sur les
taux rennes restant égales le cheval est
encadrée par les jambes qu'il ne doit
dépasser ni vers l'intérieur ni vers
l'extérieur
raccourci
[Musique]
les transitions longitudinale ou
transition des allures ont pour but
d'apporter de la franchise dans le
mouvement en avant de la fluidité dans
la lure ainsi que l' équilibre de
l'attitude générale les transitions
peuvent être montante ou descendante
d'une allure vers une autre dans une
même allure le cheval doit être préparée
avant chaque demande de transition pour
préparer le cheval le cavalier assure un
contact avec la bouche et redresse le
haut du corps pour assurer son assiette
la transition est ensuite demandé par
une action simultanée des deux jambes en
même temps que la cession de la main et
une légère avancée du buste qui allègent
leurs seins du cheval
lorsqu'un cheval et flexible à la
manière quand il ébauche irisé ennuis il
peut très bien être en quelques en
quelques semaines ou quelques mois être
tendu comme me le demande ce en
compétition en compétition ils attendent
un cheval qui va être beaucoup plus
impulsionnelle beaucoup plus tendue que
ce qu'on souhaite dans l'équitation on
va dire artistique et une équitation de
loisir
ce travail doit se poursuivre jusqu'à ce
que les réponses soit immédiate et ne
présente plus aucune hésitation dans le
travail des transitions une assiette
profonde et le soutien du haut du corps
sont les principales l'aide du cavalier
[Musique]
avec le travail sur deux pistes
commencent véritablement le dressage fin
du cheval pour arriver à ce niveau le
cavalier doit avoir appris à
parfaitement ressentir les moindres
réactions de son cheval qui jusque là ne
se déplacent ainsi que sur des lignes
parallèles côté du manège ou sur des
cercles l'épaule en dedans qui est un
exercice d'assouplissement majeur qui
doit être exécuté correctement
l'incubation contraire au sens de
déplacement est telle que les épaules se
trouve maintenue sur une piste
intérieure à celle des hanches
après avoir un curé son cheval sur des
cercles correct le cavalier fait un
dernier cercle entamé au milieu du petit
côté du manège et qui comprend le
passage du coin et le début du grand
côté
le cavalier déplace les demain vers
l'extérieur sans tirer la jambe
intérieur touche légèrement et lâche
alternativement à chaque foulée le
cavalier peut se faire aider par un
observateur se plaçant dans laxe du
cheval qui aura pour charge de vérifier
que les membres de celui-ci se déplace
en avant sur trois lignes celle du
milieu étant superposer au diagonal
externe
au début il faut se contenter de deux à
trois pas des pôles en dedans et harris
et il est bon de faire de temps en temps
un petit cercle d'un rayon égal à la
dimension du cheval et de revenir
ensuite à l'épaule en dedans lorsque le
cheval d'un correctement plus de pas sur
le grand côté
il faut veiller à ce que son poids reste
sur le postérieur intérieure et non sur
l'épaule extérieur
le corps du cavalier doit rester au
centre du cheval et non à l'intérieur
face au niveau de travail le cavalier
doit sentir le degré de cession du
cheval et doit céder dans ces aides
proportionnellement à cette session
la pluie est un déplacement latéral dans
lequel le cheval est incurvé dans le
sens du déplacement et se déplacent
parallèlement à lui même dans l' appuyer
à droite la jambe droite maintient le
curve à sion l'impulsion en restant à sa
place son incurvation s'opère autour de
la jambe intérieur et les épaules
doivent précéder légèrement les anges
dans l' appuyer à droite la jambe droite
maintient le curve à sion l'impulsion en
restant à sa place
la jambe gauche pousse la groupe vers la
droite en incitant le postérieur gauche
à venir davantage sous la masse la main
droite indicatrices du pli continue son
action toujours à la base de l'encolure
sans exercer de traction la main gauche
régulatrice appuyé sur l'encolure en
incitant les épaules à se croiser
lorsque le cheval 7 dans ses hanches il
faut être très attentif à ce que la
jambe extérieure cède également la jambe
l'intérieur devient alors prépondérante
car agissant dans la région de la sangle
elle a un effet spasmodique qui fait que
le cheval a tendance à tourner la tête
dans ce sens quand le cheval exécute
bien ces exercices commencé à le plonger
dans un coin est allé demander quelques
foulées d'appuyer tête au mur en
veillant à conserver les épaules
toujours près du par bot
lorsque le cheval connaît ses
différentes sortes d'appuyer on peut lui
demander d'effectuer des contrôles
changement de mains de deux pistes
appuyé au début du grand côté vers la
ligne du milieu et en arrivant à celle
ci revenir à nouveau sur le grand côté
dans le sens opposé à ce moment c'est la
jambe intérieur qui agit d'abord
[Musique]
pour
et
[Musique]
le cavalier peut avantageusement cd
d'une ligne de piquets plantés dans le
sol pour effectuer des contrôles
changements demain et pouvoir travailler
la régularité dans ses changements dead
[Musique]
oh
comme pour les pôles en dotant le cheval
exécute les appuyer au pas et au trot un
bon rythme de progression doit être
rétablie on aura soin de ne demander d
appuyer autre que lorsque ceux ci seront
exécutés parfaitement au pas
[Musique]
et
ouais
vous
[Musique]
il ne faut pas pratiquer de façon
exagérée les appuyer car le mouvement de
latéraux flexion qu'ils imposent aux
sabots se traduisent par des
compressions cartilagineuse du côté de
la pluie et des tractions ligamentaire
du côté opposé les mouvements de
rotation accentue ses contraintes et
entraîne une torsion des rayons au su
des capsules articulaires pouvant causer
des dommages importants chez le cheval
qui seraient trop sollicité
[Musique]
le galop et une allure dissymétrique
pouvant permettre de réaliser toutes les
figures et exercices sans restriction
la qualité du galop des portes
essentiellement de la qualité du départ
tu as le cheval est dans cette position
incurvé major
circulez ma jambe gauche et leus entre
mon poids est à l'extérieur j'ai la
fesse droite et je pèse sur la fesse
droite et au moment du départ
j'avance j'avance la main gauche
j'engage l'assiette et j'aime la jambe
gauche
le départ se fait en redresse un peu on
redresse un peu cheval on ferme la jambe
gauche en avance la main gauche il faut
avancer un peu la main gauche pour que
le cheval avance cet intérieur
double à ma gauche a et je perds ma
jambe gauche
le cavalier devra placer ces aides est
incurvé son
cheval exactement comme s'ils voulaient
effectuer un cercle une épaule en dedans
ou d appuyer
le départ au galop paraît diagonale et
dans un premier temps la façon la plus
pratique d'obtenir des départs correct
en prenant bien soin de ne jamais
laisser de cheval trotter avant deux
parties
le but but final c'est de mettre le
cheval dans le confort dans une position
qui lui permettent de faire ce qu'on lui
demande ce qu'on lui demande d'abord
c'est de nous porter c'est un 1er mai
première chose donc mécaniquement il
peut pas se mettre de ne pas se mettre
dans une position différente de celle
qui lui permet de porter donc là qu'on
était belle doit faire comme une voûte
être libre de fonctionner et tout le
travail du cavalier finalement le
travail de ré soeur c'est vrai qu'il a
besoin d'outils cdd le cheval à semaine
dans une position correcte quand le
cheval est parfait déjà ce qui est ça
facilite les choses
ce qui arrive a très très peu de chevaux
et si je fous là sont chers mais quand
ils sont quand ils sont pas tous
parfaits et il ya des bons chevaux qui
ne sont pas parfaits qu'il faut aider à
mettre dans une bonne position
on a une colonne vertébrale complète
d'un cheval qui est qui est une vraie
colonne latérale vous avez ici
les sept cervicales jusqu'à celle
célèbre là à partir de la première
dorsale jusqu'à dix huitième ici ce sont
toutes des dorsales bien sûr et puis si
lambert et le sacrum dans une position
normale lorsque le cheval est bien
constitué à une position normale
on a on à la moelle épinière qui est sur
un plan qui est rectiligne
ce n'est que les apophyses épineuse de
la colonne vertébrale qui donne cette
forme au dos indo plus ou moins creusée
ou pas selon la qualité du cheval bien
lorsque lorsqu'un cheval est monté par
un cavalier un jeune cheval la tendance
à supporter le poids du cavalier en se
creusant un petit peu ce qui provoque
des petits hématomes là entre ces
apophyses et
et à l'inconfort il s ensuit un
inconfort qui peut être plus ou moins
accentuée si en même temps le cavalier
provoque une traction sur les reines qui
a tendance à faire remonter l'encolure
encore plus on a le creux du dos qui
s'accentue qui devient de plus en plus
important hélas les douleurs deviennent
importantes surtout au niveau au niveau
du garrot de la base du garrot et puis
on a ici entre la dernière cervicales et
la première dorsale on a une espèce de
ciseaux qui se produit et un pincement
très important qui est qui est très
certainement à l'origine de pas mal de
pathologies on a ball forcé en un mot le
malmener ça sert absolument rien parce
que le problème il se trouve à cet
endroit là est sûre c'est sur sa colonne
vertébrale
lorsque le cheval se passe à la fois le
garrot et la cervicale il il est dans
l'incapacité de faire quelconque
mouvement on dit là qui s'accumulent 1
il peut s'accumuler à les avoir même
allée à reculons se pointer et toutes
les défenses qu'on a
lorsque le cheval ne veut pas avancer
c'est pour ça que le mouvement n'a l'on
peut régler certains problèmes mais le
tout les défenses conte à vienne de
l'inconfort de la cathédrale lorsqu'on
veut vraiment aider le cheval il faut
faire des étirements l'art en premier
lieu regardez on va baisser
l'encolure l'ensk l'encolure se baissent
automatiquement déjà parlé la ch'ti cité
des tissus le dos le dos va monter et
s'ouvrir un s'ouvrir et c'est apophyses
épineuse s'ouvre comme un éventail à ce
moment là il n'y a plus de douleur là et
à partir de cet exercice qui est
l'abaissement de l'encolure et bien on
va pouvoir demander au cheval de devenir
s'engager sous la masse un parent c'est
postérieur et là ça lui sera possible
parce que il n'aura plus de blocage au
niveau du garrot voilà pourquoi la
descente d'encolure l'abaissement de
l'encolure est très importante
puisqu'elle libère les tensions qu'on
peut avoir à ce niveau là les apophyses
épineuse qui plus est lorsqu'on veut
incurvé un cheval
c'est naturellement un cheval ce
cinquième à l'envers dans les virages
c'est précisément pour ouvrir cet
éventail des appeaux visé bineuse par
exemple lorsqu'il tourne à gauche c'est
à dire vers moi il va se tourner il va
se plier un vers l'extérieur du cheval
de vers l'extérieur du virage
naturellement ce qui est en soi une
bonne position pour lui puisqu'il se il
se fait pas mal aux vertèbres mais dans
la mécanique il a tout son poids sur un
seul pied et à ce moment là il ya
d'autres pathologies qui peuvent
apparaître surtout au niveau des pieds
pour lui il est beaucoup plus
intéressant que le cavalier l'aide à
tourner dans le bon sens c'est-à-dire un
5 e hve dans le bon sens si le tournez à
gauche il faut donc qu'ils s'incurve à
gauche et à ce moment là on fait sortir
les alpes du sud les apophyses épineuse
du garrot vers l'extérieur du virage et
là aussi on est en libère un toutes
tensions qui peuvent se provoquer haut
niveau au niveau du dos d'où
l'importance donc d'abaisser encore sûrs
dans un premier temps de d'incurver à
cheval pour qu'ils puissent se
rassembler pour qu'ils puissent venir
par la suite a beau de boudin travail
très
très suivie par la suite venir se
rassembler donc avoir un dos rond tous
les chevaux ont ce problème là s'ils
sont montés avec trop demain s'il sent
monter aussi sans locomotion si d'où
l'importance de l'exacte précisément
d'avoir le moins demain possible d'avoir
une main fixe à cheval avec une assiette
correct qui ne va pas ne va pas
provoquer ces abaissements de du dos
quelle que soit la discipline que vous
souhaitez pratiquer un cheval bien
dressé est un gage de plaisir de
satisfaction et de sécurité
qu'il s'agisse pour vous d'effectuer un
parcours de sauts d'obstacles une
reprise de dressage ou un parcours en
terrain varié vous devrez toujours avoir
à l'esprit de placer votre cheval dans
une position le mettant à l'abri de la
douleur et de la souffrance
attachez vous à ressentent
tout ce qui se passe sous votre selle et
apprenez à réagir à la moindre
indication de votre monture le plus
souvent par la cession
voilà grande roue
que j'ai fait
en utilisant ces bouchées il ya 25 ans
j'ai trop je suis tombé sur le livre de
vauché le édition originale de 1848 et
c'est quelque chose qui m'a complètement
bouleversé ma vie à cheval
quand j'ai lu les flexions den bossche
j'ai dit c'est ce qui c'est la solution
qui nous faut absolument et je
connaissais pas à boucher je connaissais
pas l'incidence que cela pouvait avoir à
ce moment là et ça m'a aidé mais tout au
long de 12 salles je peux dire que ça a
changé totalement mag à cheval il ya eu
aussi c'est ce qui m'a amené à aller
voir au livre à qui était le bauchi rist
disons de 25 qui est le boucher risque
du samedi 20eme siècle et parallèlement
à ça les lectures de tous les élèves de
boucher comme rab comme favreau de care
break c'est son édile de schleck c'est
quelque chose que je n'oublie jamais
qu'il n'y a pas un seul instant quand je
monte à cheval qui me sort de l'idée